so I will get to my cats Christmas album
in just a moment but the first happy
project for awesome everyone if you're
not already aware what the project for
awesome is it's an annual charity event
where lots of YouTube creators to get
together to spread awareness and raise
money for lots of different charities
however given that this year is the 10th
annual project for awesome I figured I'd
do something a little bit different and
so instead of telling you about one of
my favorite charities I'm going to let
my cat
Gideon tell you about one of his he's
written me a little letter to read out
to you all because he is a little bit
camera shy aren't you Gideon hello my
name is Gideon and I am a cat I used to
live on the streets of East London but
now I live with Charlie I'm Emily I am
lucky because they have given me a safe
place to live which is something are
many animals around the world do not
have for storm animals the natural
habitats are being destroyed and others
are being hunted to the point of
extinction this is not very nice
this is why my charity is the Wildlife
Conservation Network they support
conservationists who help the animals
who are endangered animals are becoming
extinct faster than ever these days
circus work is very very important one
of the things I like about the Wildlife
Conservation your work is you can choose
what animals you want to help like small
cats maybe and then 100% of your
donation will go to the field took us
after species who know that I great
strategy donate to them or vote for them
for the project for awesome
thank you very much Gideon the cat now
something else that Gideon wanted to do
this year was create a perk for the
project for awesome IndieGoGo page and
so he and I have been working on a
Christmas EP titled a very Gideon
Christmas so without further ado here is
a little taster for you
- here / - so when is cold and Oh
Christmas tree
I love
[Music]
Christmastime can't continue it is Mary
beloved here if you don't celebrate it
that's okay mistake Oh makes you happy
holidays so there you go if you would
like to donate to the project for
awesome and get your copy of a very
Gideon Christmas and just click on that
thingy over there all of the proceeds
from the project for awesome are going
to charities either picked by them or by
you and if you'd like to vote for
Gideon's charity to be one of the ones
that gets a portion of that donation
money then just click on the link down
there and vote for this video happy
project for awesome everyone and I will
see you again very soon bye bye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool thank you very
much for watching everyone do check out
my previous video if you haven't already
fun science video about misconceptions
about evolution at but most importantly
go and get yourself a copy of a very
Gideon Christmas it is a real thing I
promise it is very much real five songs
they're all pretty short but very
enjoyable definitely do ya know a voice
is lovely Gideon it's not annoying in
the slightest I see you next time bye
Gideon is my microphone